sono matite giganti come giganti disco
oggi nuovi team e skype room
perché sì un vestito di rosso perché una
felpa di youtube perché oggi che
otterremo da youtube sono troppo curiosa
sipro mar la non mi piace se volete
vedere altri skype room mi raccomando e
anche per portarci fortuna sono farina
ma porta cosa potete vedere io ho
cambiato vestito mi sono vestita di
rosso bravo mi piace mio avvertito in
modo gli stivali lo zio lo adoro
bellissimo invece evitare che siamo
pronti a una tutti gruppo e mettetevi
con i preti concorre siamo inseriti su
instagram andato a seguirmi su internet
e iniziamo subito pronti via
entriamo nel mondo delle schede ma che
cos'è questo persone ha detto che vuole
mangiarmi adesso capiamo
ok un po brano un'ora si salva cliccando
sul play babau evita stranamente non è
ancora molto moltissimo penso che
bisogna evitare questo finora è facile
abbastanza facile la nostra amati
tornano carriera di maialini
ma pure tutti si spiaccicano ai piani
odio queste scacchiere le odio un po
devi andare molto molto piano che
proviamo questa personale c'è scappare
impossibile
wow ma che bello che bello che sta
stampa straniera kobe alieni questi cosa
sono dei marshmallow questo è molto
difficile quando arriverai quatar alla
fine peggiori testo di fatto non ci
credo wow qua bisogna far presto
prelancio inizia a diventare sempre più
difficile queste skyroom non bisogna
saltare nei pezzi rossi li vedete che vi
interessa continua a morire nella
scacchiera vabbè io attraverso
l'arcobaleno dai blu portami fortuna blu
ok dai ci stiamo a posto e blu ma anche
solo rotto o no il verde sono sicura che
il verde mi porterà fortuna ha mai fatto
bravo e celeste ci sono quasi piano
piano piano piano viola
lecco vita ne è arrivato al marco
salerno tra una panda quasi sono le tre
strade da scegliere è quello marrone voi
mi avete scritto nei prossimi forse
esilio per vedere qual è la strada di
passare tipo attraverso così con
inquadrature vedere quella che non puoi
passare attraverso ma copre riesco a
portare attraverso tutte poi se non ho
capito non ho mai fatto e vorrei in ogni
abito allora io non vedo chi parla di
questa persona si è viola dal g ok sto
arrivando ad una bellissima questa
stanza siamo nello spazio con tutti gli
arcobaleni tutto colorato di marrone e
poi viola grazie
finalmente siamo di nuovo lettere ora
stai super attento qua a bisogna stare
attenti a quella barra rossa no sono
caduto all'ultimo a nozze la barra
giustamente seguendo poche altre più
attaccata
adesso ce l'ho fatta un pelo c'era la
palla che mi fermo qui devi andare piano
piano piano mi spiace grado
[Musica]
questa persona ha detto no quello è
sangue ma devo prendere la barchetta dai
ti aspetto ciò che lo circonda cosa
preferisci la barchetta un elicottero e
capitale allora andiamo per l'elicottero
dai a donald i propri e non va bene
andiamo nella barchetta no anche poi
essere tipo fra ma vitale sprofondato
detto che dobbiamo notare fino alla
possiamo saltare su queste piattaforme
non lo so quale ci sono altri play
button di youtube però queste celeste
che carino a mano mica panini sono le
scale di ok attenti a non cadere
c'è scritto non riuscirei mai a scappare
non gay come bisogna saltare sui granchi
che cosa chiede ma chi è questo gigante
e più vitale e stato proprio numero che
bello e dove devo andare
adesso che questo fra www sempre più in
alto
un personaggio di robot gigante wow
e salta sulla nuvola salvato così
chiamati perché perché questo
rappresenta youtube prima cosa gli altri
il play che bello salviamo ho sentito
qualcuno che moriva rai ora vitale una
volta lire sopra la lettera c'è notare
la parte rossa della lettera certo non
toccare il bollino rosso comunque questo
rappresenta il di unboxing su youtube
primis non immagina di banchettare
ovvero figlio è stranamente sono più
avanti io di te come era possibile
salviamo anche io sto andando poiché la
somma altro portale vai piano si sono
già scritto non riuscirai a sconfiggermi
gli organismi bassano dei baffi perché
bisogna portare sui bambini e ora
bisogna saltare che non so cosa dei
personaggi di rho blog siamo quasi
[Applauso]
dal tar al volo salta salta un attento
perché bisogna sempre no ma bisogna
stare nella piattaforma e poi risalire
sopra che dai ti aspetto io ho salvato
non ci credo vitale più avanti di me
conoscerti che arriva agli emo andare a
devo andare su quelle nuvole con c'è
qualcosa di rosa sarà e ci siamo quasi
salviamo ora bisogna salire gli occhiali
da sole perché è difficilissimo forse
bisogna stare sulla stanghette degli
occhiali ecco difficilissimo qua vedi
avuto evitare se la fanno solo salutato
la stanghetta ha preso la rincorsa del
rio bravo ragazzo ha detto che stiamo
appetitosi vuole mangiare lo si guarda
questo unico
più che di un tipico piatto ma dice che
quindi youtube ci vuole mangiare
[Musica]
ok abbiamo provato ma secondo me bisogna
stare attenti a queste cose rosa è si no
ok devi saltare quale il lato dove sono
io ma no è difficile qua sta diventando
selezioni più destinati a meno male si
può star barili riuscito ad andare
avanti
gli ha fatto eco vitale dai puoi far se
la sono fatta ora bisogna portare in
divisa che come società smetto quella
barra nota nella prevista a saltare
velocissimamente infatti il mio preso
io non ci credo ho salvato ma questo è
difficilissimo salvato ucci rivista dire
ma devi stare attento
vogliamo a scalzare no è troppo
difficile forse si è preparata ma dovete
mandare da qualcuno conviene andare su
questa adesso salta sull'altra brava è
riuscito a saltare dritta bravi ragazzi
non potete capire la sarà un corsa senza
volto 0 barbra ritratta non proprio
quando ce l'ho fatta non stavamo
registrando va bene fa niente abbiamo
dobbiamo saltare su questi giorni mamma
che carini nuovo vitale si e spiazzi
caso
vabbè troppo dei tanti ricordi ma
finalmente è che questo dice riesci a
superare il mio livello
ok ma vabbè mi sono incastrati successa
una cosa simile
no se sceglievi dall'altra parte potevi
ricominciai possiamo farcela perchè ci
sono come non detto
ce l'ho fatta di questo andiamo come
salire su quei diamanti che ti aspetto
più avanti ok ci credete che è vitale
via superato non è potuta non ci credo
anch'io di saltare
guarda che cosa rimane una miniera
quindi veniva dal tar equa ed i brutti e
si è mosso per piccolo non è possibile
che fare mi sta superando la parte qua è
difficilissima come farcela cui fare
devi prendere
perché qua brava brava quasi fatto
risaltare questa cosa di wow un editore
puro d'aria
questo dice euro ha accelerato bene
piano piano ma che si sono di minecraft
di minecraft ok finora tutto bene uno è
caduto nella lava si sente il fuoco si è
fatto bene italia rocco dietro faceva
fatta recapitare una ruga metri con i
difficili battaglie è venuta nella
cucina da incubo ma che cordon renzi
quando saltare sulle mele questo sarebbe
il sogno di vetro finora le mele anche
noi adoriamo le mele e farà tempo la
coincidenza ma ho i miei orecchi di oggi
sono a forma di mela porteranno fortuna
ma vediamo a chiudi ci sono io dice
anche il bar mesetto che cai
questi sono i fornelli non sapevo io che
youtube vorrebbe farci lo dicevo
all'inizio una crostata di sta venendo
fame come si fa a passare si passa in
mezzo ai fornelli qui appunto non finire
dentro il fornello verrà emozionato
una crostata di mele un cestino con
tante mail
wow salviamo no mi sono spiaccicato
sulla prostata di lamponi e di bene
stare qua o faccio un labirinto e per
evitare attento perché qua morirai molto
spesso sono anche una visita a
prepararla piano piano piano sono qui di
estradizione brava ce l'ho fatta se un
burki gente faceva fatta fatevi salvare
ma devi salvare hai fatto a salvador ai
tuoi farcela beh io salgo su ma cosa c'è
scritto c'è scritto qualcosa nella mia
gonna v20c poverino vita neri vostro
futuro a casini allora qua mi dice buona
fortuna ne avrai bisogno sono dentro una
scuola qua ci sono delle matite giganti
che bello dentro l'acqua sono matite
giganti come non detto temperini giganti
gomme giganti finalmente arrivato anche
vita o meno venute le azzurre in mezzo
alle matite giganti ha mandato
sull'ultima prova a passare qua a lato e
no non mi fa passare ai tv matematica
non mi ricorda mg maggior minore stiamo
quasi vitale anche un 3 0 ci ha fatto su
una gamba
comunque ci sono dei fogli tipo pagelle
inciampo sempre sulla stessa gomma io
perché queste scompaiono ecco quello che
volevate dirmi forze questi due
scompaiono e rimane solo quello quindi
dovrebbe essere quando vediamo stessi
mesi per nuovo come ultima è forse
quello sì comunque ci sono tutti di
dollari che volano questo ieri dunque
bisogna evitare la barra verde difficile
acqua oltre ad andare piano bisogna
anche saltare
e difficilissimo e curare molto vitale
io sono già morta 50 volte perché è
difficilissimo che poteva svegliare il
piano devi anche saltare
eccoci qua stiamo sui capelli è davvero
difficile questa escape room di youtube
troviamo così non ci credi tu bravo ma
ci sono i nomi di chi è riuscito a
marina il mio nome
sì vita e purtroppo in una volta
indietro però davvero difficile questo
libro notevole ma questo era un
ragazzino tutte le tv lasciate un bel mi
piace vedere altro che illudere cliccate
su uno di questi quattro casellina e
buona visione